Strange don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous fine I won't
if i die it's your fault
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new shangshi video spider-man no way home video
explaining the marvel phase 4 timeline a lot of
people asking because there are a lot of scenes
that seemingly connect between what's happening
between those two movies and a lot of other stuff
during marvel phase four if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos i will be doing a bunch of shang chi post
credit scene videos easter eggs full breakdowns
happening later this week after the movie comes
out also even though it's not totally related
here there's a really cool scene during this
new trailer where you actually see the mandarin
watching all these video feeds here from all over
the world from his operations in the 10 rings in
this one monitor you can actually see the scene
from the very beginning of the first iron man
film when the 10 rings are hauling tony starkin
to broadcast to the world that they're holding
him hostage but during the shangshi movie we see
wong finding the abomination mortal kombat style
in this tournament before shang chi fights
his younger sister so when wong appeared in
the spider-man no way home trailer inside the
sanctum that was covered in snow top to bottom
like winter had exploded inside the sanctum he
and doctor strange the other initiates there
have these thick winter coats on and spider-man
then shows up at the door to ask doctor strange
if he can make it so mysterio never revealed his
identity one more day style when wong walks into
the scene he yells at doctor strange like oh hell
no don't you dare attempt that spell that i think
you're talking about it's too dangerous don't mess
with the multiverse alternate timelines alternate
realities it'll only go wrong doctor strange
very sarcastically promises not to then wong nods
and walks through the portal with a couple big
luggage bags packed like he's going on vacation
then doctor strange winks at peter and they
get to the one more day of it all with them
going down to the basement of the sanctum to
do the spell that they said they wouldn't do
so after the trailer came out we watched it a
billion times everyone was making the joke that
wong had packed his bags all his junk up and was
heading off to fight the abomination like taking
a little vacation to go kick some butt and earn
some sandwich money but here's the thing about the
timeline of all the marvel phase 4 movies they're
all over the place even though they're releasing
all the marvel phase 4 disney plus series and the
movies in a certain order the order that they're
releasing them isn't the order that they happen in
the timeline it also explains where the eternals
movie fits in here too because eternals takes
place right after avengers end game and we've
already had a bunch of marvel phase 4 disney plus
series set in present day so the timeline is kind
of a mess for a number of different reasons thank
you very much loki and sylvie currently it goes
like this so we're using avengers end game as our
starting point like the end of avengers end game
which ends around summer 2023 the loki series
literally starts while avengers end game is still
happening so technically that's like the first
new big marvel phase 4 thing in the timeline
the tva comes to arrest loki before the
avengers have had their final battle with
thanos before the blip happens even though they
jump around in the timeline during the loki series
in the finale ends at the literal end of time most
of the effects of what sylvie did killing he who
remains with all the kang variants breaking free
in their alternate timelines the true multiverse
like if you think i'm bad wait till you meet my
variants that's happening and everyone else in
the marvel phase 4 timeline the movies even the
marvel phase 5 stuff in the future that's going
to happen that we don't know about yet all these
characters in present day are feeling the effects
of what loki and sylvie did while their series
and their movies are happening it's just that
it hasn't gotten so bad it hasn't escalated
to the point where you see a bunch of kangs
from other realities busting into the mcu while
these series are happening really good example is
like while falcon and winter soldier is playing
out you have to picture them in like a distant
part of the multiverse there's a giant war raging
and it just hasn't made its way to the main mcu
universe quite yet but then right after that the
eternals movie takes place over the course of the
week after the ending of avengers end game because
of that seven day countdown to the emergence that
they talk about in the trailer the emergence of
that new celestial that's ready to be born because
it absorbs so much cosmic energy from the infinity
stones in the hulk's infinity gauntlet snap
although technically iron man also snapped
his infinity gauntlet right after that too
you have to imagine that that just made things so
much worse but then the events of Wandavision pick
up three weeks after avengers end game so like
a couple weeks after the eternals movie then
falcon in winter soldier takes place about six
months after avengers end game then right around
the time that's happening right around the ending
of falcon and winter soldier the black widow post
credit scene happens with yelena belova and val
then right after that is when the events of the
hawkeye series are going to pick up like a couple
weeks after this black widow post-credits scene so
maybe like seven months after offenders end game
maybe a little bit more than that but a lot of the
hawkeye series will take place in new york city
and obviously you have a lot of spider-man stuff
happening there so most of hawkeye will take place
before the events of spider-man far from home
spider-man far from home takes place eight months
after avengers and gabe because remember it's like
the school vacation the school trip the year after
avengers end game so technically we're into 2024
when spider-man far from home is happening then as
you see from the spider-man no way home trailer it
starts literally right after spider-man far from
home right after he's been doxed by mysterio and
everyone starts freaking out the events of the
shang chi movie are taking place while most
of the falcon and winter soldier the black widow
post credit scene stuff is happening like shangshi
takes place later during 2023 after the effects
of the blip have chilled out and life has kind
of gotten back to normal mostly like you see the
vibe in the shangshi trailer when they're parking
cars and it seems pretty chill in san francisco
so all the reality warping multiverse craziness
the spider-man and doctor strange cause with the
sinister six villains happens after the events
of the shangshi movie also without getting into
spoilers the shangshi movie is mostly concerned
with explaining how and why he is going to cross
over with avengers 5 and work as part of the
new avengers team that's why so many of the shang
chi trailers incorporate so much avengers footage
in setting up where they're going with the story
of the shang chi sequels because they do plan
on making sequels and pushing deeper into the
mythology of the character that they established
during the first movie like the shangshi movie
sets up a couple really big things but doesn't
completely answer every single question about
where things come from exactly how his power works
because they're saving a lot of that for sequels
the same way that they do with all the other
avengers movies like the thor movies the iron man
movies captain america movies and they combine
that teaser setting up the sequels with the big
avengers crossover teaser and during that scene
it's pretty clear that none of the nonsense
with the snow-covered sanctum has happened yet
spider-man and doctor strange haven't completely
broken the main mcu reality yet as crazy the
shangshi movie gets like none of the spider-man
no way home craziness stuff has happened yet
so that's why i say that the shangshi movie seems
like it ends somewhere around her just before the
events of spider-man far from home just because
there's so little time between the beginning of
that movie in the beginning of spider-man no way
home the only big project on this list that i
haven't really talked about during marvel phase 4
and present day is the miss marvel series because
it's not clear from the trailer footage in that
if it's also happening during 2023 or if it's
happening later in the timeline they've delayed
that series till early next year it seems like
so we probably won't find out about that for a
while but don't worry about it and even though
there is a whole lot of wong and abomination stuff
happening in the shangshi trailers they're not a
really really big part of the film like that's
just happening during this big fight scene here
without getting into big spoilers the movie
just goes on to other big things it's a largely
self-contained movie in the way that marvel movies
nowadays tend to be very self-contained even
though there are big crossovers that happen within
the films like thor ragnarok is a good example
because there was so much doctor strange during
that it was obviously a really big crossover and
obviously we have a spider-man doctor strange
crossover and spider-man no way home but for
the most part the movies themselves are fairly
self-contained like it's not like captain america
civil war where you have every single avenger
character crossing over in all their stories are
given equal weight wong does serve an important
role in the shangshi movie but he's probably not
as big a presence in the film as you might think
he is just looking at the trailer footage is the
same situation with doctor strange in spider-man
no way home like obviously very critical
to the plot of spider-man no way home because
of the way he weaves the spell that helps them
mess with reality to erase spider-man's identity
from people's memories using alternate timelines
alternate realities but the way they talked about
the movie it sounds like he's only in it for a
little while like he is stepping into the new
mentor role that was previously occupied by iron
man tony stark and really how much iron man was
there inside spider-man homecoming like a couple
key scenes couple important scenes but really all
told he was probably on the movie for less than
like 15-20 minutes and it seems like spider-man no
way home is supposed to be around two and a half
hours long maybe not quite two and a half hours
there was a recent news posting that claimed it
was going to be two and a half hours but that
might not be completely accurate that might
just be a placeholder it's the same situation
with all the tobey maguire and andrew garfield
spider-man rumors like how much of the movie are
they actually going to be in probably not a whole
lot but i think the idea is that if things work
out well they'll just set up the concept that they
could always come back in bigger ways in future
films and then we have the whole idea of the
post-credits scene sort of pushing forward because
doctor strange multiverse of madness happens right
after spider-man no way home like if you thought
they break reality during spider-man no way home
wait till you get to doctor strange 2 with scarlet
witch and find out what she's doing although the
funny thing now is that you can actually point
at almost every single marvel character that's
at least in some sort of cosmic story is having
broken the multiverse in some way like you have
loki and silvie that very literally unleashed
all the kang variants and started the new kang
multiverse war you have spider-man and doctor
strange completely scrambling the main mcu reality
trying to combine it with a couple alternate
realities and things going completely off the
rails you have scarlet witch with a dark hold and
she has the power to travel between dimensions
so the community meme of doctor strange walking
in with a pizza and everything being on fire is
just so apropo like everybody everywhere you
look in marvel phase four is doing their best
to completely break the multiverse later this
week once the shangshi movie does come out i
will talk more specifically about what's going on
in the post-credits scene what they're setting up
for avengers 5 and how this is going to connect
with all the other marvel movies in the timeline
and speaking of doctor strange breaking things
my full what if episode 4 video is going to post
wednesday just like normal that's going to be the
dark doctor strange episode where he just goes
completely off the rails make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss those
everyone click here to learn what's going
on with the sinister 6 in the spider-man no
way home trailer and click here for that brand
new black panther 2 wakanda forever first look
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!